and most people are chasing the macro
win all the time and they're not looking
at all the micro wins that they can feel
really good about to get them to that
macro zone and so a lot of people set
goals and they don't follow through on
them and if you can just get and I can
just get every single pocket of 24 hours
right as best as we humanly can the rest
of our life is going to take care of
itself
rise and shine
it's an espresso time good morning
belief nation it's evan my one word is
believe and i believe in you i believe
you have an amazing gift inside to you
that i want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message create micro wins over
to you lisa nichols this whole piece of
my book abundance now i wrote it a while
ago and it's amazing in terms of just
talking about and breaking down what's
the difference between a macro win and a
micro win and a micro win is that
smaller goal that's you could see it's
attainable you get that instant result
and most people are chasing the macro
win all the time and they're not looking
at all the micro wins that they can feel
really good about to get them to that
macro result because if you create 5 7 8
10 micro wins guess what now you're in a
rhythm now you're building some
consistency now you like the way it
feels and then before you know you look
up and go whoa there's that macro win
that huge goal that i thought was a
hundred
miles away it wasn't a hundred miles
away it was seven eight eleven micro
winds away you need to be really careful
about the goals that you set for
yourself because every time you set a
goal and you either accomplish it or you
don't you're creating an identity for
yourself and so a lot of people set
goals and they don't follow through on
them even a little goal you have a micro
goal you say I'm gonna go off and do
this I'm gonna eat this for breakfast
today I'm gonna go work out today
nothing that's gonna take a ton of time
not making a million YouTube channel
subscriber video right it's all these
little micro goals that we set for
ourselves if you do not follow through
on them then you're creating that
identity for yourself that I am the kind
of person who sets goals and it's not
follow-through and that's a big problem
because then when you set a goal that's
actually really important to you then
you'll let yourself down and you won't
follow through on it and so the one I
like to think of the classic one for me
is a snooze button if you snooze raise
your hand a lot of people hit that
snooze button in the morning it's not
great for you for a whole bunch of
health reasons but the one I'm most
concerned about is the mentality is the
mindset is the identity because think
about what you've done you went to bed
at night and you told yourself I'm gonna
wake up at seven o'clock tomorrow
morning or whatever time right I've set
a goal that I'm gonna wake up at seven
o'clock tomorrow morning 7 o'clock comes
what do you do you hit the snooze button
the very first thing that you do every
single morning is say I set a goal for
myself it's okay not to do that goal
today that's how you wake up every day
what are the chances that you're gonna
then go off and have an amazing day and
that's the I didn't II that you built
for yourself it's okay for me to set a
goal for myself and not have the Micra
win and you may think that that's not a
big deal but if you're doing that
consistently if you set a goal for
yourself and then secretly in your head
you're saying yeah you're not gonna do
that then guess what you're not going to
do that that's the problem and so you
have to be really really really careful
about the goals that you set for
yourself
the big ones yes yes rational ones yes
but more importantly to build the
identity of somebody who follows through
is the micro ones it's the small daily
ones that checklist that you create for
yourself of your to do of what you want
to get accomplished today you need to go
off and do those things
and when you do you feel great like I
did it and you're building that in the
positive direction of the I'm the person
who follows through on the things I said
I'm gonna do and if you look at that
checklist and three things are not on
there you didn't do them you're gonna
feel bad about yourself and you're not
going to believe in yourself to go off
and do the other goals that you set for
yourself the next day and so that
identity building as I am the kind of
person who when I set a goal I follow
through on it is really really really
important and so you have to be very
careful especially in the micro so I
feel no daily different goals that you
set for yourself and the more that you
set a goal and you follow through you
build that equity within yourself you
build that bank so that you feel like
you can complan girl and a bigger goal
and a bigger goal and a bigger goal and
every time you take away every time you
don't do it you're less likely to want
to follow through the next day I've got
a special bonus clip for you but before
getting to that I want to know question
of the day do you snooze in the morning
be honest leave it down the comments
below
really curse to you what you have to say
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus
[Music]
small wins matter I mean we sometimes
think that an epic life occurs one
Sunday Sunday Friday afternoon when the
stars line up and something
revolutionary occurs and what I'm
suggesting to you with great love and
great respect is a great life is built
not by revolution a great life is built
by evolution small and steady wins the
race what you do every day is far more
important than once you what you do once
every decade I want to really think
about that idea what you do every day is
simply your life in miniature and as you
live every single day so you're crafting
your life what you do over the next hour
is is really building your future and if
you can just get and I can just get
every single pocket of 24 hours right as
best as we humanly can the rest of our
life is going to take care of itself so
small wins matter you know the moment in
front of the customer where the pull was
to go average and you become merch
enough Wow
set you up for the next day of a way of
being of WoW the little win with your
family when you feel like watching TV
set you up for another win the next day
a little win of getting up at 5 o'clock
and running your morning routine sets
you up for a habit of a 5 a.m. Club
morning routine small daily improvements
over time will lead you to stunning
results tiny wins are the way to
greatness and that's one of the things
life has taught me when you look at the
great companies whether it's an Amazon
whether it's you know some of some of
the tech startups coming out right now
whether it's a Zappos whether it's a
FedEx whether it's a Nike whether it's a
General Electric whether it's some of
the you know the little shops in your
neighborhood that we really admire
because people still cook the food with
love or they serve the food with love or
people have an attention to detail great
companies are built by those small
steady optimizations every single day if
you look at any great product it wasn't
just one day that built the great
product it was a culture and a mindset
daily innovation and optimization when
done consistently over time which led to
world-class even-even relationships a
great relationship it's all about those
small daily wins when done consistently
leads to a lifetime of love I was
walking in the woods last week and there
were these there was an elderly couple
walking in front of me and they really
stood out because they were moving fast
and I and they were also like they had
these ski poles and so this I mean this
is the autumn in my hometown and they
were walking with these ski poles and so
I sort of joked as I walked by them
because pretty much only the three of us
in this deep forest and I said you're
missing the cell and they started
laughed and we actually walked for about
half an hour
and we started going pretty deep and
they said to me you know we've been
married 52 years and I said fifty-two
years what's your secret and the woman
says well we've I've had to put up with
a lot which made me laugh and then it
was all about the little small daily
things they did to foster a lifetime of
love raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that we believe
that people with passion and not one
drop of most self-worth depends on your
it's something Sammy I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
roses success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details